a girl grown in a lab that's ever worked
for direct will see more again so
Morgan's a movie directed by Luke Scott
who is Ridley Scott's son and Morgan
this group of scientists in a lab in the
middle of nowhere have created an
artificial life are they created a
test-tube baby accelerated intelligence
accelerated growth then something
happened she freaked out stabbed a lady
in the eye so kate mara is from
corporate she's coming here to see if
hey maybe this girl is a success or
maybe we just flush her down the toilet
so now you have a movie about an
artificial life-form that was growing in
a test tube in the middle of nowhere in
a small confined lab this is a setting
that's going to lead to good decisions
and nothing bad happening right no no no
I feel it there's talk about what I
liked in this movie first of all I like
the girl who plays Morgan she's the girl
from The Witch and if you've seen the
witch she was good in there she's good
in here there's something about her she
has like a vulnerability and a
fierceness usually someone's either the
fierce one or the one who cries all the
time but this girl rides the line of
both and you buy the fact that she's
both that gives her depth and relevance
and I usually hate nepotism I just do
but I love the fact that Ridley Scott
made a few phone calls and got Paul
Giamatti in this movie he's doing a
psych eval with Morgan I mean I his
characters an idiot but Paul Giamatti is
great in the movie he's in it briefly
but still you saw this in the trailer so
I'm gonna count this as not a spoiler I
mean he goes on and on about how he's so
good at his job and he needs to build
rapport in a relationship a trust
relationship between him and the
subjects I'm about two minutes later
he's screaming at Morgan now he could be
screaming at her just to get a reaction
because that is his job but he genuinely
looked like he was irritated with her
and he was screaming at her maybe it
looks so convincing because Paul
Giamatti is just that good of an actor I
don't know really what you have here is
kind of a bore fest that's a cliche ass
movie given the premise that it is Earl
in a lab who starts to lose it you've
seen that [ __ ] a hundred times over and
the saddest thing is this movie doesn't
commit to its point this movie tries to
be one of those pseudo intellectual
movies like it's a mirror to the face of
humanity is she really any worse than us
wouldn't we do the same thing in her
shoes the first fifty minutes of this
movie is boring as [ __ ] and relies on
character set up among characters that
aren't interesting enough to have
character set up so the character set up
bores the [ __ ] out of you too it's a
downward spiral right there you see that
down the rabbit hole
there was an interesting stuff in the
trailer actually does happen is about a
half an hour left into the movie and at
that point it's just it's not as
interesting as the movie wanted to be
done messing is the case of the movie is
bad because the trailer showed you that
it was going to be this exciting movie
and then it actually wasn't that is in
the movie and that is a problem I'm
saying this movie is messy by any
measurement you want to give it there
was a fight that went down in the movie
that I yet you feel it because of the
sound though someone got punched you
felt they got punched they got kicked
you felt they got kicked it's just all
in the impact of the sound but it was so
choppy at a point I started counting the
edits like counting the cuts and if I
felt that I had to start counting the
cuts rest assured there were a lot more
leading up to that point but at a point
I was like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
I got to 25 before 10 seconds I swear to
god you thought I had a lot of jump cuts
no you ain't seen nothing yet and
granted any fight scene is going to have
a lot of edits but when it's
hand-to-hand combat that close with that
many edits you can't even tell what's
going on it doesn't give your brain
enough time to register what's going on
and in the end I can't even tell you
what happened in that fight the acting
was fine the premise and potential is
great but it's a movie that rode two
lines and it feels like it's the
brainchild of someone who was just
divided as to how they wanted to do it
do you go the intellectual route but
then possibly bore half of your target
demographic or do you make it with this
girl gets loose in the lab and she's
losing it and she has to be stopped
really it doesn't know what it wants to
be so it doesn't actually succeed it
either it's not executed well at all
which is a shame and I will say I'm not
gonna remember Morgan and t-minus one
day ya already forgot saving grace might
be down the road when we find out this
movie is actually somehow a Blade Runner
prequel I could see that happening it's
if it's in there if there's an easter
egg in this movie I totally missed it
and wait for the blu-ray special
features alright guys so Morgan have you
seen it what did you think about it was
your favorite movie about someone who's
been artificially created it's vague
enough who knows whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]